the dismantling of the trump immigration
program
underway tonight the biden
administration is allowing tens of
thousands of asylum seekers
into the u.s until their claims are hurt
national correspondent william lachaness
looks at the impact of this move
from nogales arizona we do not have the
resources available to house and
accommodate these migrants within our
community
an urgent plea to president biden from
the democratic mayor of del rio texas
i am pleading and requesting with you to
please put a halt to any measures
regarding the release of immigrants
awaiting court dates
friday the biden administration dumped
president trump's remain in mexico
policy
releasing 25 asylum seekers into the u.s
it is just such a sense of hope and
relief that something concrete now is
happening
so to say that we're going to start
bringing in more people
it's it is of concern health experts say
admitting up to 300 foreign nationals a
day
which is president biden's goal risk
spreading the virus
the last thing we want to do is
introduce even more variants
without identifying them first yet other
migrants cross illegally
and dangerously a woman gave birth
saturday in the banks of the rio grande
in freezing temperatures
an x-ray found these men crammed in a
tractor-trailer
and rescues are almost double from last
year if you're coming from honduras
guatemala
you can pay anywhere between two
thousand to six thousand dollars it
strictly depends on on what it where you
want to go how you want to get in what
sector you're going to cross in
so it's an awful lot of money republican
senator lindsey graham
visiting the border says the democrats
immigration bill is doa
with the gop if you don't change the
magnets to illegal immigration
it will never stop people will keep
coming by the thousands to hundreds of
thousands
so right now the border is closed
because of covin allowing agents to turn
back
90 percent of all migrants without a
hearing but that will end
and when it does they fear they'll be
overwhelmed without help from congress
brett william ness along the border in
arizona william thank you